can i talk to you for a second can you
guys shut that door
nice are you good so much up there yeah
um
um
i am really struggling with just
i
have going on in my head about how much
i dislike myself as a human being
and i just like this is really hard i'm
trying so hard to be on time and
i just i over talk and i
share things that make people
uncomfortable and
then everybody's like oh we need you on
the floor and
just oh i i hate the sound of my own
voice
here's the thing and i'm gonna start a
talk show
in uh you have landed a job
because you have been being you your
entire life and that's what got you this
and now all you're doing is you're
adjusting
for this schedule and this thing
maintaining
what why you're here no no no don't deal
with that
okay just say i'm ready and we're going
okay i'm ready and we're going here we
go
wow work so hard
at things because i am full of flaws
oh my god i'm so screwed up i'm so
imperfect
i've been so broken so many times in my
life
and yet none of that can be an excuse to
stay that way
or to be upset or angry or ever take
that out on anyone else or
to have that be the reason that you
didn't get out of it and go
to the next place it's it's i just want
to get it right
i just want to get it right i want to do
everything to the best of my ability and
figuring out where
all the compartmentalizing we have your
back we're not going to let you oh i
know you guys have my back
but we're going to do it in the room
okay right here
we're here for you we're going to
encourage when you're launching a show
like this
under these circumstances it's a bit
overwhelming for all of us and i can
only imagine
how that feels for drew
so that day you know was just really the
perfect example of who she is and what
she's about
and it's about honesty and it's about
knowing knowing the moment and realizing
that we have to live up to this moment
our job is to keep that flow going like
you don't have to keep everything i walk
in here i'm like oh my god seven
segments i got this
usually it's like it's overwhelming i'm
like in my a.d sarah like stop
there's four stories here's your stories
do yours news first
commercial break get ready ready for the
next it's our job to prepare you for the
next
beat you don't have to know everything
you've researched it
be in the moment and it's one story at a
time it's one thought at a time
if that thought takes you through drew's
news so be it
she challenges all of us and she
challenged us
big time to say we can't do that show
that we did last year we can't
it's not the world has changed we need
to present things bigger
better we need to take chances and risks
that includes going live that includes
doing virtual interviews
um and really pushing the envelope you
know what else is okay
when you make a mistake you just keep
going
people are so hung up on it has to be
perfect it really doesn't
so that whole sitting stuck in it
feeling sorry for yourself
being stifled you know
i don't know we don't have to be and
i know there are people who have helped
me out of those times so i know i'm
capable of helping others out of those
times
but when you see that you can break
through and get out of them and not
have it be an excuse in life
to be broken then it's just so
liberating
[Music]
treatment for vaccine available
5 31 and you're still in the damn
bathroom
katrina
enjoy the go good morning salsa
how are you doing today
what time is it exactly it is 8 41 42
so i guess that means i'm on time
[Music]
and this is proof that we don't stay
stuck in life
and i'm so omar
fear it out it may not look pretty but
we would get there
i have to figure out life or i'm not
going to be as good of a friend as i
demand of myself
you know i don't want to do any of this
in a vacuum i
i since i was seven years old i've been
engaging with people
out on the street and in every venue i
go to my whole life
i have never lived an existence that
isn't interactive with people
go to work i love you too i will go to
work thanks to you
i love you so much i love you so much
but i love bread too but when she came
out with like
i love bread i would have better falling
off
go fix yourself
live from new york
um well i think it's been around eight
months
since we were in this office together
you and me omar
and um yeah i had my work and girl
moment
and i had a desk it's here
we're back in the building we get to do
this show they're letting us do
this show
i feel like we're in the fourth quarter
of 2020 and everybody's trying to get in
position
to figure this year out
we all get to be human beings in this
job
and when jason says every friday
going into the weekend go live your life
and bring it back to the show
that is what gives me hope for everyone
being happy in their job
and then hopefully trying to make a show
that is
outward but very personal all right
words of wisdom to take us
into the night and who has it
i will give you the words of wisdom a
brief moment of clarity says
the wisdom that have carried me through
life i'll make it super quick i
never miss a good opportunity and so
this is the quote that i picked out ah
that is fantastic
baby you'll move mountains and will you
succeed hello everyone
[Applause]
my words of wisdom are from big boy from
a big boy's neighborhood
when you become successful you're going
to get busy
stay busy but never be too busy
there's never satisfaction without
stress it's how you handle it that makes
or break the situation
put your good heart and your good mind
into it you're you
you'll overcome the obstacles you've
always had the power my dear
you just had to learn it for yourself if
you're not doing what you love
you are wasting your time don't think
outside of the box
get rid of the box howard say it can't
be done critics
say it shouldn't have been done and
creators say well done we're all brought
here
for a reason
we're doing it this is it thank you for
doing a namaste moment really sweet
every morning when my grandmother would
wake up and she would have an orange for
breakfast
she would stop in the moment before she
would peel the orange
and she would say at this moment this
orange
has not seen the light of day and that's
what our show is right now
it's the orange you get to cherish this
moment where other people haven't seen
that orange that's gonna be in the light
of day for everyone to see we get to
treasure this we get to hold this close
to us and then
we get to peel that orange and everyone
else
that's what i got today dang thank you
so much and i couldn't
and i know that i am the kind of person
who believes you have to earn
everything so
i feel lucky that we are able to start
and you know
kind of like my life the rest is up for
me to screw up or not
[Music]
[Music]
i'm waiting for you